sorry for the delay my name is Robin
we're playing the outlast to demo which
is free to play on the ps4 I have not
played this nor have I seen much footage
I've seen a little bit uh so this should
be interesting yeah again geez I've
heard things about this demo was that a
warning ash of red who cares let's do it
Oh
I have the same thing in my backyard
it's the tea
hey man my glasses
alright alright night vision Lynn ok so
i don't i know that there's like a
battery life on this right
more game
I'm also jacked up on a lot of caffeine
so might be a little jittery
alright so this this is good i can see a
little more jesus oh no whoa
just your horse cow
he's quick I guess I have to go this way
towards the man with a knife all right
crouch yes I got a little sidestep look
cool Oh a little reversal
gosh nah it's just bird haha oh it's
just bird yeah and I know oh is this my
breath we got to hold my breath in dire
situations alright it's kind of cool
like this jewel this that's this is
creeping in itself well good morning
well what's this free linear
look like it was close it's just a
ceiling look like was the door was
closing oh this looks fun all right
yeah I get those flies away soon I want
to read that Oh looks like some kind of
classic birth
normal that's how I was born
what they're just they're just popping
out babies and just throwing them over
here what watch my savior shall we all
that I've been wrong today
reminds me i left my last girlfriend oh
yeah camera duh I can't really am I
waiting you can't really move please
leave me why is my night vision is this
star you idiot
oh yeah so my got reload the bats okay
my battery wasn't dying
oh this is pretty clean hello children
what time is it battery go because this
camcorder takes double a alright let's
gather this grandma hold it that's right
I know this mechanic man I'm going to
pop this camcorder at some point and
it's going to be a dude looking at my
face
that inner monologue Jessica and when we
were
come on
I love us
whoa what was that
mana me my high I don't even know it hi
I gotta hide
I'm not gonna lie this is really
uncomfortable what the hell was that
[ __ ] what what was that what was that ah
my heart is off rhythm now that's not
cool oh right is this a secret entrance
back out of my memory cool it's let's
not go there and it's gone whoa wire all
right this is getting real [ __ ] weird
sorry for swearing
Jesus like that it remind me of the
thing from I don't know what I feel like
there's a fad nowadays with like
multiple jaws like a flower just like
hey here's the inner look of my head
whoa
yeah [ __ ] is right
probably saved my batteries huh take me
with you
me
I Rocco gone bro nope peace yeah
probably got a room wrong side of that
nitrous on an acid trip running away
what's your cooling on there yeah thanks
I'll show my way I appreciate it spit
fun alright
and the camcorders like it kills your
distance it makes it like even worse
sometimes I feel like your view of the
distance
my father
stop
a couch sadness
huh
box
come on you're
this I don't I'm so turned around I
don't even know where I'm supposed to go
now
and there's so many of them
Oh a collectible
uh
and then I am so turned around
some light over here that's good go
there sense not good oh those bodies
nope
it's a weird slide
oh this is where I came from isn't it
great up
let's follow the moon
Oh
can't see him
[ __ ]
[ __ ] doc what go I'm out later guys spit
real stay up what ma my glasses I can't
see my glasses hi how are you no thanks
thanks
I'm not gonna lie that felt weird cool
well that was the demo I guess that was
fun uh wow I didn't know is that short
oh it's cool thank you guys for watching
oh the lobby is at two p.m. today
Pacific so tune in for that and yeah
happy tuesday everyone take care now
you